- Do talk about the Devil's Hell, though.
- And make sure that people
know the Devil's Hell
is a reference to your butthole.
- (Laughs) That's right.
Make sure you say, "Uh, sorry.
"I'm gonna order in a moment.
"Sorry. I'll have a water.
"I'm talking about my anus."
- I call it
the Devil's Hell.
- The Devil's Hell.
(slow, romantic jazz music)
- Bad things that any of
your exes have done to you.
You look like you're a little
bit spiky and full of rage.
Any like, skin issues that you have.
(laughing)
And if you don't believe in
evolution, keep it to yourself.
(slow, romantic jazz music)
- There's nothing more
romantic than sharing a salad.
I'll order for the lady
always, if you're a guy,
always order for the woman.
- And women love that.
If you're a man on a first date,
make sure you sort of
tell her what she's like.
- Yeah.
- Make sure to show her you through her.
"You're gonna have the Caesar salad and
"I'm gonna feed you those anchovies."
- Right
(slow, romantic jazz music)
I think if I was on a first
date and a man was checking
his phone at the table,
I would think that he
kind of doesn't know what's up.
- I think you want to have a
phone handy so you can show
the person you're with
your prior convictions.
(slow, romantic jazz music)
Read the room.
- Yeah read the room.
But I always like to hug.
You know unless, they're like,
you don't like them.
Then you should handshake
and then they'll know
this is over.
- What I'll usually say is, I go,
"Can I hug your lips with my tongue?"
And they're confused by
that and by that time,
I've already run out of the room.
(slow, romantic jazz music)
- "I'm so sorry!
"I'm having such a bad time!
(laughing)
"I'm so sorry!"
- "I just realized."
- "It's so random but I'm having
"such a bad time with you."
- Oh my god.
- "Your personality is just
absolutely the opposite of
"what I was hoping for
and I um, I'm so sorry,
"this is so weird but I have to go."
(slow, romantic jazz music)
- Well probably Frank's Red Hot sauce.
(laughing)
(slow, romantic jazz music)
- You gotta bring the
cheese in your purse.
- You gotta bring a warm cheese.
I like to eat a lot of
the cheese before the date
so that there's a real
gurgle in my stomach.
- Oh, great. Yep.
- I feel like a lady--
(both mumbling)
- Split it.
- Banana split it.
- 2014!
(laughing)
- If it's a male and a female on a date,
I think the guy pays and says,
"Ha ha, you owe me."
(laughing)
(slow, romantic jazz music)
- I know it's not 2014.
- It's 2015.
- That was a joke.
- She was doing a joke,
we all know it's 2015